yo they had said that there was a port
in time where you were in the nba that
you like chose to still live in
queensbridge in qb is that true
yeah that was a gift from the courage
like um
because my mom
went out when i made it i was like mom
we're gonna move out
go chicago she's like nah i'ma stay in
queensbridge so my mom stayed in
queensland for a couple years
and so i kind of redid the apartment in
queensbridge
but it was like i was trying to do
something else
but my mom just wanted to stay in hood
so i mean for the most part i just
stayed in the hood
and then um you know uh i was looking
for an apartment back home in
queensbridge i got my you know
i was always close by
it's crazy because you think like you
make it you become a millionaire you're
supposed to kind of go the other way
right
i mean you should you're not supposed to
think you it's it's like you're most
vulnerable at home when you when you
make it because you that's where most of
your haters are probably at that's not
for me i got a lot of love in my
neighborhood
you know i'm saying so it's not like
other neighborhoods you know um
you know our neighborhood's a little
different
but you know but i think like when you
make it like professional whatever
you're doing music sports
you have other opportunities you know
what i'm saying it's things you could do
yeah that you don't really need to get
you you should be doing actually right
right right if you get if somebody write
you a rapper you get a five million
dollar check
you should be thinking differently you
should start thinking differently yeah
yeah there's opportunity for you right
so that's probably like not everyone
sees that
you know jay-z he from the hood but he
obviously had a huge plan
and when you when you start planning
that early
i mean you know sky's the limit and that
and that's kind of what i'm hoping more
people do what what happened for you to
kind of change your mind state
it was weird man because like i really
like queensbridge i'm very proud
queensbridge guy
you know so like for me it was all about
queensbridge
you know growing up you know nice mob
deep and we want to keep that going you
you rep it you know and it's all about
us that's it yeah yeah you know what i'm
saying and then um
that was such a that was like a
big part of my life
you know what i'm saying growing up
from when i got drafted when i was in
the nba
you know and i wasn't coming into the
nba to make friends right and i did i
mean i got friends but initially
my friends was back home
i'm coming here to just you know to work
to work it's a job to do what i got to
do maybe lock somebody up and then like
go back home
you know and go back home my friends
and that's kind of i mean that was a
gift from the curse and i was really
focused on my game and focus on my like
kind of my hood
you know what i mean like i was there
and my family too like my family but
i wasn't really
nothing else really came with that